this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist today we're doing a fan
favorite edition of cosmic queries and I
got with me I've never had him before
Godfrey hey then I'd freeze up
Godfrey tweeting at Dodd freak Godfrey
comedian not get Godfrey commedia didn't
use your last name Don Chima that's you
I thought you MA
okay that's fine it's too long long too
weird
it's you weird it could sound Japanese
some type of all the bathrooms two doors
down we can email we're sending it to
you a night I need an extra push I go
you need that last bit to drop not one
of the cosmic query if we start out with
scat jokes at the beginning there's no
place to go after that anyhow no it's
cool having you on man thanks I listen
I've been watching your shows I see you
on a Bill Maher show real time the hot
air I know I just try to put it right
but you know how you step in you say
little thing let the scientists talk I'm
proud of that man right there that's
right he's articulate and smart in your
cosmos you get it's awesome because my
he's to watch cosmos my dad with Carl
Sagan oh yeah took over the reins and
they're nice when I saw you a 14 year
old kid you met calls he gave him you he
gave you his number his phone number so
I had people say to me I should I should
have told him that the bus really
couldn't come through and I have to
spend the night in Cornell because he
gave me the phone number case the bus
believed action to the city I believed
it wouldn't happen no but I was too
honest back there to on Oh Mike will you
like was he like the nicest dude ever he
was very polite and very he was it was
almost he cared I mean that's really
right arid care about the trajectory of
others who would come behind him not
enough people do that in all the
professions one called it's called
comedy yeah my friends suck hey man can
you tweet for me I don't know it might
take my followers yeah that crap but
Carl was like yeah he was WOW and
genuine person
yeah he could have at least given you
his turtleneck and his jacket too sweet
just his elbow patches his elbow patches
we're awesome
and you said cuz I we were talking
before we started the show and I thought
that he was a guy who said billions and
billions of stories he only said the
word once at any billion time and Johnny
Carson Johnny Carson was the one who
doubled up on him is it imitating and
with no I can do Johnny Carson right all
right let me hear okay what I did not
know that
Wow stuff Carl Sagan I go watch this Wow
billions and billions and then Ed go oh
oh oh can I get some Johnny Carson fan
low okay for everyone over 60 I like
that boy does Johnny Carson okay go
ahead we got some this is a cosmic
queries edition on cosmic phenomena I
haven't seen the questions before hold
from our fan base and so you got him
you are alum you have the steering wheel
say deal so let's bring it on okay hmm
I'm gonna read one from a patreon
patreon these are oh yes yes so these
are people who support the show and so
basically they extort her set up to get
their questions asked first patreon was
a name like an alien named Cosmo so I
thought it was the Klingons the patron
my name is this guy's name it's a little
annoying
okay well why'd you just spell your name
like CY le so it looks like sy o welcome
but it's Kyle trying to be a jewel that
show you don't like when Christina it's
wit a--they and
hey it's all okay here we're okay I was
a patreon kyle Yocum he's from Tennessee
all right I think I'm gonna use an
accent for this one okay that's Texas
more than Tennessee okay what's this man
as long as you don't know where it is I
don't like how you specify I'm at night
sometimes I say some I got some so don't
think that I couldn't okay so what's
this this good one that's her see
backwood Georgia okay how about this
alright here we go how's that one that
is ranch Texas okay okay hmm go right
back to the same one yeah that's a
little better
Tennessee up from Tennessee yeah there
we go
Tennessee okay here we go cow Yocum
here's the here's the UH the question
all right ready here we go
okay the math of Einstein's equations
shows nothing can reach the speed of
light if it has mass but if we
discovered a mass less particle that
could be accelerated beyond light speed
and travel backwards in time the instant
it did would it begin to decelerate
again since acceleration required
forward movement in time and going
backwards in time would be the reverse
if so it seems it would just be stuck at
exactly light speed could this be why
photons are always traveling at that
speed hmm like he was repeating
something that was obvious but no but
obvious to whom to say would it reverse
it's almost like he said the incident
did would it begin to decelerate like
that's almost like a common sense okay
so the way the way it works on the other
side okay would you cross over these
time steins equations so anything with
mass cannot accelerate to reach the
speed of light okay that's not that it's
never been seen nor is it theoretically
possible and
tried it so we have experimental
evidence theoretical foundation and the
like
so things that travel speed might have
no mass at all like photons which he
correctly noted right okay so now we we
my my brethren of decades ago my
academic brethren hypothesized a
particle that lives faster than light so
it doesn't have the problem of
accelerating to the speed of light right
because it just lives faster than the
speed of light
Wow okay so if you have such a particle
what would happen to it well it would
live backwards in time hmm and that we
call this particle tachyons Wow from the
Greek Takas meaning fast like a
tachometer is the same route so that'd
be like Usain Bolt's to Cathy on we
finally got the word Tac y hy is a
common route when people are refer to
things going fast where speed is the
measure of that so we hypothesized that
there might be a particle called
tachyons the attacks are really cool if
you think about it because if you if I
sent it to you now you would have gotten
it before I sent it Wow so that's kind
of cool so yeah yeah so you can imagine
so I've thought about this here's an
interesting scenario if you could text
via cat tachyons right so I see you walk
yeah and and you okay so there's a
banana peel in your path okay okay so I
don't want you to trip on it okay okay
so but you already tripped on it okay
so I send you a tachyon message that you
get in the past right okay you got there
were you with me okay okay yeah so I
send you text and I say watch out for
the banana peel oh I'm already on it
then and then your your smartphone
jiggles right you pick it up yeah read
the text yeah and then you no longer
looking where you're stepping right then
you slip on the better
well that depends on your own package I
mean if you got sprint so it may be that
changing yes the past might not be
possible because the very act of me
trying to interfere with you stepping on
the banana peel is what actually made
you step on the banana peel you you are
not paying attention to the banana blue
because you were reading the text that's
right that I sent you to not step on the
banana peel so are you saying that is it
true that everything is happens at the
same time well so so there's another way
to think about that and saying if so if
you have like a yardstick yeah you can
say all the numbers are on that
yardstick at the same time they're all
just there right you can be eight inches
30 inches right there just there so
imagine a time line that's just there
you're born on one end you die on the
other end it's just there so wherever
you you could jump in jump out join
yourself at any part of your lifetime
right
so therefore in a sense your timeline
when viewed from a higher dimension is
all happening at the same time time Oh
deep I think I kind of got so so so so
this is tachyon thinking tachyon brain
already thought about it yesterday
except re thought about except the
timeline has to be thought of in the
higher dimension that allows you to see
the entire timeline all at once okay
that's the only point that in our
current dimensionality yes we are
prisoners of the present yes forever
transitioning between our inaccessible
past and our inaccessible future okay
then we just live in the present
that's what it is all we can do we all
we can do but a higher dimension being
would say hey just rejoin who would that
be Buddha but for many images I've seen
illustrate there's a higher dimensional
being nah but and who would that be
though this is what I want to know you
want to know
from a human perspective now who's this
higher being it'd have to be maybe the
Dalai Lama if he meditates to a certain
point okay so if you meditate but what I
wonder is if meditation is happening
interior to your brain and not ejected
Lee verifiable by others outside of your
brain so so if so if your mind
experiences it yes then you go back in
time in your mind sure but we're talking
about a physical reality not a
neurological Riya and meditation is all
about your neurological reality but
don't you need isn't mind and body the
same thing or no oh no because we can
pith your brain and your body you think
you can do to your mind and your bodies
are still there that's chosen hey I
could take out this part of your brain
and you can't speak this other party
brain you can't recognize faces it's
other part of your brain you lose your
appetite I can do we know enough about
the brain to know how to howto what the
causes and effects are let me tell you
something here's the reason why we don't
know a lot about the brain you let me
tell you why you got you got you got
this you got got this not this would
have got this what is it the reason why
we don't know we still have mysteries
about the brain is because we're using
the brain to try to think about it so
why would the brain give you that secret
brains like I'm gonna give you all my
stuff so you're asking a very deep
question yeah and the mind yes
understand itself we don't know and
guess what what you just thought about
the mind gave you so I as I think about
it we are Assemblies of atoms and
molecules okay in this universe right
that the universe itself created right
and we're on a mission to decode and
understand the very operations of the
universe itself okay so as has been said
before we in a way huh are a pathway for
the universe to figure itself out wow
that's that's heavy
I jus the fact that we can even
approximate some of what is real in the
universe gives me hope that our mind can
figure out our mind
mmm I think they would have to be
something outside the mind to figure out
the mind probably to do it best
sure you have right now we're kind of
groggy along it's like an unborn child
deducing the nature of its mother you
can't do it cuz you're inside exactly no
idea what your mama looks like unless
you have all these mirrors you can stick
out Wow
that would be scary you have like an
alien sorry China's proper word that's
scientifically proper if a hand came out
to look at it's all goodness wait so so
right so here you go so on the other
side of the speed of light yes all the
properties of tachyons include last I
checked up on them that it would take an
infinite amount of energy to slow them
down to the speed of light Wow and
they're capable of infinite speeds so
that's what so if you want to take AI
steins equations and flip them to the
other side knowing you can't pass
through the speed of light these are the
properties what's going on that's heavy
yeah that's fast yeah what is it 186,000
hundred eighty two miles per second wow
that was that pretty good very
significant figures and the speed of
right let's go let's go take it was a
good one Yocum take just took most of
this segment okay okay okay
no no no no no you don't like that one
oh okay
how about this one this is pretty simple
a radio farmer from Facebook how much
space is there inside a black hole ooh
okay so you can measure the volume of
the event horizon of the black hole one
of the most poetic terms ever amazing
given what it does to you mr. Cooper
this one way
you don't come back this is the zone
within which there is no return
yes event horizon event horizon of no
say we gotta be saw a event horizon the
event horizon and now another hours the
event horizon one man the world starring
Samuel Jackson where's that black hole
of course it there's no complete movie
without Samuel Jackson right wait what
was the movie with Mark Wahlberg do his
horizon it was a horizon movie oh no no
that's that's a drilling movie but it
was horizon no had horizon right so this
cursor right there be an oceanic horizon
haven't seen the movie but that's my
guess right haven't either I saw the
trailer right so in the universe we
think of the horizon of the universe in
the same way the horizon of this at sea
Deepwater Horizon deepwater horizon but
what a horizon so your horizon at sea
you can see to that edge but you cannot
see beyond it right so if you had no
other data you might think that was your
entire universe Wow
unless you sort of moved towards the
horizon right and if you're in the
middle of the ocean the horizon doesn't
really change very much it's still water
so you could think there's water forever
right and and brave people like the
explorers of the 90 of the 16th and 17th
centuries they kept going until they
found land right I figured they thought
they'd come around the backside and come
get to the other side of the land they
were on right but there was more land
there's more like a new world as it of
course was described so so so you can
measure the volume of the event horizons
very cleanly but but for reasons that
remain a little bit mysterious when you
run the equations or instance equations
of what happens inside of a black hole
it births an entire other space-time ok
an entire other universe so if you can
survive the fall into a black hole you
can come out what you will see is the
entire future history of the universe
you came from
unfold before your very eyes because
time slows down for you and everything
else would look like it's moving fast
okay in the entire future history of
your universe unfold before your very
eyes and another universe opens up in
front of you so that the black hole yeah
as a portal to an entire other what we
call space-time continuum right it's
higher other universe that comes out of
in Stein's equations the same equations
that give us out the structure of our
universe so no one's gone in to test
this go back out but everything else
about his equations work so it gives us
high confidence that maybe this has
happened in there too I mean what I want
to know is okay that's why we talk about
there's some variants of multiverse
thinking where every black hole is just
a conduit to whole other you know you
think it's a whole other universe we
have this intersect in two connected
Warren's just stars being swallowed up
little swallow star stars and again it
becomes more math yeah never planets
though we swallow anything things near
it it comes near anything and nothing
comes back nothing could well well
there's a way know some people Hawking
radiation Hawking radius yeah Hawking
radiation so Hawking Stephen Hawking
that Stephen Hawking
he's famous legitimately famous for a
whole lot of reasons yeah one of them
was he calculated that the energy field
surrounding the black hole remembering
equals MC squared yeah it's the
equivalence of mass and energy as energy
field can spontaneously create particles
right particle pairs matter and
antimatter pairs one of which falls back
into the black hole the other escapes
into space okay so a black hole can
essentially evaporate very slowly
particle by particle evaporate by this
phenomenon so that it can lose mass
through its energy field because mass in
energy or one in the same right and this
is so this is called Hawking radiation
so yes do come out but in a very
different state than you went in Wow
okay yeah yeah so God Godfrey goes in
garbage atoms come out
but then evaporation happens well we
call it about we call it evaporation I
don't know we don't know have a bad word
we should come up with another word
that's the closest collaboration it's
like particle by particle Wow we gotta
take a break when we come back more
cosmic queries awesome with Godfrey on
Startalk we are back on Startalk cosmic
queries Edition and I got Godfrey amen
yeah it's up Godfrey tweeting at Godfrey
comedian yes that's right that's a lot
of characters to give up to your Twitter
handle is it Godfrey Kavya it's the only
way it's the only way I wanted to be as
short of just a god no cannot do that
I'll show up not dude I would say well
lowercase G okay lowercase because it
cuz people will come up to me and go oh
dude they can do it like in an arrogant
do they call you God for sure you know
me I'm like yes they do okay yes yes
they do and you're a sinner yes are you
ready so these are cosmic phenomena I
haven't seen the question so bloody mom
bring them on I'm bringing you let's see
what I'm going to see what you get I see
yet I got here Joshua Shoop Twitter okay
aliens are so far away they can see our
entire history as it's happening is that
why they don't want to come here yes
just let me clarify why that would be
the case yes if you are at any distance
from anything you're looking at right
you see it not as it is but as it once
was
hmm I see you not as you are but as you
were for billions of a second ago whoa
so light takes about a nanosecond to go
afoot a nanosecond to go for a billionth
of a second so about four feet from me
right now I see you as you once were
four billionths of a second ago so now
let's put let's put a civilization on
Alpha century the nearest star system to
ours that's four light-years away before
light
Oh seconds away from me right alpha
centuries for light-years away so
anybody there is watching if they were
could get our signals they would be
seeing earth what was going on four
years ago there was another campaign for
president obama was smashing that dummy
what's that dummy's name
oh that Mormon guy said guys they uh
know he's so bad at Romney Mitt Romney
yeah you could see him getting pummeled
okay so they would be watching though
that the last few weeks of that campaign
okay all right in real time in real time
as it was unfolding because the light is
just arriving at them at the time Wow
okay
so now if you go farther or so here you
go there's their galaxies that might be
six there is 165 million light years
away
why did I pick that number yes the stuff
that was happening here on earth 65
million years ago is only now just
reaching this just reaching them just
reaching them say let's check out the
earth TV earth channel there we go this
is a to t-rex imitation exactly so I'm
sure that's what they sounded like
[Laughter]
so they would see the extinction of the
dinosaurs because that's when the
asteroid struck meteor a meteor struck
the size of Mount Everest that's what
they would be saying they would watch
that in real time so so there's a lot of
interesting history on earth that
shouldn't preclude alien visitation at
least maybe they visited the dinosaurs
and Wow then you could ask why didn't
they help him out you know I and you
know if they were really checking so I
was thinking they wouldn't come because
of Trump know nothing you did but that
was a very recent phenomena that has not
had enough time reach any planets beyond
our own solar system imagine so there's
no understanding of recent current
events that will do any aliens anywhere
in the galaxy I don't want to Trump you
but I go wrong
that's what he did the whole road wrong
so that's interesting I didn't think you
would actually see the dying of the
Dianetics ting ssin of the diner's yeah
yeah
so yes so they would have access to
pending on their distance okay I would
have access so what are some events so
let's say I mean well it's a good
example we'll were one in World War two
pretty tragic times in the history of
the earth 70 80 hundred years ago and
they might say these people have messed
up right right and say when we will not
come anywhere near this is this is the
in summary yeah
aliens have never visited because
according to them there's no sign of
intelligent life on earth
Wow there it is there it is yeah that's
that's got it okay I think you nailed
that all right I think okay I got called
kneeling it by the way way say it's
called kneeling kneeled it you know you
kneeled it slow faster than their no
because I'm looking at you from some
light years away oh okay good come back
you get one time till I come back okay
all right you get one of those personnel
slow maybe people are slow because of
light years they're not really here yet
so there's no such thing as being cement
Elise Lowe it's just their perspective
it's kind of okay stop there yeah all
right I have another question cosmic
phenomena bring it on this is by William
Morris Facebook ok what's a hand way
about two to three pounds next you can't
wait you think I was born yesterday I
just wanted to see that what's a hand
way there's no science behind that huh
that's it
next that's it what is the wishes we
should call the first warp drive a hen
way so that wherever they gland they say
we got to fix the hen way
run that joke at flee across the galaxy
that was awesome
well this is in I'm old enough to
remember f-troop attitude that's Larry
Stewart Larry Storch and what was it it
was like the the cavalry right and the
Indians right and the in the the in the
Wild West and the name of the tribe were
the haka we Indians huh Khali and I
think in the first episode
you remember F Troop and I remember I
think I'm remembering this correctly in
the first episode the the cavalry meets
this tribe and they say who are you guys
and that the India where the heck are we
Indian say no whit they didn't know
where they are cause they think they got
lost
the Indians then it got lost they say
where the heck are we
[Music]
and they said oh you're the head car no
way to go we're the Hakkari India yes
that's I think that's how that happened
in the very first episode
are we Indian yes just caught that again
I'm telling you no ears away if the heck
are we a dutiful 12-second Hikari
because use the way you said it cuz
that's how they said it all around the
episodes but it's F Troop is a sitcom ok
sitcom man that's good what's the runway
you knocked that out so this I'm gonna
call if I invent the warp drive is the
Hemingway warp drive headway wait yeah
rap oh you know that sounds better
ok yeah yeah ok here we go ray Clark
Facebook ok if the moon were to somehow
be blown apart mm-hmm would end up with
a set of Saturn like rings yes not what
would happen yes yes temporarily we
would have rings ring system an awesome
awesome yes using awesome the way God
intended awesome to be you yeah not it
would be awesome if you could pass the
salt no no
in my day we use
awesome when we discovered the cure to
polio you used awesome when we walked on
the frickin moon do you believe that I
don't know we were talking about that do
you believe that they landed I just want
to know you're asking the wrong the
astronaut should have been black because
we would've been more excited upon
landing you see we have just landed on
my ear baby how we do baby you get the
cosmonaut baby I'd be like this oh no
that's one small step for man one small
step for man one giant diaper man it's
like oh it's like it's like you know it
is
I wonder why dude score touchdown they
just give the ball to the ref we scored
like there's a thing I think the
emotions that would come about yes among
people who would rejoice in having just
landed on the moon yes are in
commensurate with how you might react in
the face of disaster if you face that on
your journey if the oxygen tank blows
okay that's the same person who lands on
the moon so you need some you need
people with ice in their veins yeah I
know Armstrong was just such a person
okay
well alright I guess but he's landed on
the moon and he's running out of fuel
okay you know about I don't know if you
knew about this we're running out if he
was because where they were gonna land
right he's there was like rocky and it
was not smooth and it was worried that
the lunar excursion module would tip
yeah he starts going sideways okay I
think very little fuel that's left
and so Houston is saying you got a plan
that puppy let no I'm good still looking
and he's monitoring how much it is yeah
you know his heartbeat was when it was
like 85 or something I mean it was some
low heartbeat okay any of us get just
when we're irritated that we're waiting
in line or something so no these were
very special set of the right stuff
okay it was truly the right stuff how
long did it take to get there three days
three days three days in the ship yeah
well how old he can tank I'm just saying
drinking Tang and sit three days yeah
three days three days okay
all right you explain to me because I
was doubting it yeah yeah yeah no no you
asked me if I believe it I don't that
one doesn't need to believe when
confronted with evidence okay that's all
who s deep wow I should tweet that [ __ ]
yeah you should you should tweet it lie
20 first time but my birthday so it
would always show the anniversary of the
landing they were to show you know
landing a moon did that the day before
that what why he was eight on the
newspapers that reported it right yes
that's my birthday July 20th is the big
deal
yes the big deal okay oh the big deal
Neal we're both Neal's okay so boom you
don't even answer that question what was
it what was the question was it was that
would the earth end up with rings yeah
we would end the Rings but this little B
why would particles are not stable um
because they'd be hitting one another
and they'd be falling and they have
energy from the explosion some would
escape others would come back to earth
so we wouldn't have like our own little
rings it's like Saturn Saturn's ring
system is in fact not stable it's not
stay no no no it's a temporary feature
in fact there's good evidence to suggest
the dinosaurs if they had telescopes
have they looked at Saturn would see no
rings at all why is that because that's
because the ring system different
calculations give different numbers but
millions of years is a common number
that I've seen yeah for the life
expectancy of the ring system of Saturn
which meant they would have been long
they would not have formed yet at the
time of the dinosaurs so stuff in it you
know things collide happen stuff happens
just cuz it didn't happen in your
lifetime that me it's not happening in
the universe so yeah it would have a
beautiful ring it would be beautiful you
think it'd be better in Saturn's
Saturdays would be my favorite silly for
it's Michael favorite planet Oh Susie of
competition ya know cuz satyrs big
Saturn's big give me some big rings big
rings big rings okay yeah yeah that you
good you good on that we're good we're
good
I got another one all right okay here we
go oh by the way by the way
tides would be greatly reduced at that
point that's true right because there
was a whole lot of other things would
change about earth women wouldn't be so
moody right it's the period right we're
sending you all the mail yeah wouldn't
it affect the menstrual cycle every 28
days
no because the phase of the moon is not
28 days oh wait Oh what is it yeah
waxing and waning what is Ilya waxing
weighs 29 and a half days okay does not
match the average menstrual cycle of
women okay therefore you cannot credit
or blame the moon for any periodicities
so it is the human female boyfriend
sooner also that there are plenty of
other mammals that whose menstrual
cycles are very different from a month
your mammals - what other mammals just I
don't you know I'm not an expert on this
right and it's just saying that the you
know mice you know just look at your
mammal is nice okay I'll just look at
any Department for that it's all about a
month nothing magical okay
relative to natural cycles that's all
I'm saying okay I thought that you know
yeah it's not it's not it's not if it's
not an exact match that means they go
out of phase yearly so this is not a
thing okay Wow all right that's I like
that well we can send him all the mail
right would it affect all our moods
though cuz they'd say the moon is full
moon it's affecting our moods okay if
you live in a city I don't know how you
can justify that given the fact that at
night street lamps are brighter than the
full moon true and you don't talk about
your moods being affected by street
lights well what brand of ball was used
cortisol levels are up oh sure but not
you can't credit or blame the moon for
that it's because we illuminate our
nighttime lives that's true that's true
right are brighter than the full most
set yeah how you know this you can only
barely read under a full moon
so you come in at night you put on
brighter lights and you can read just
fine it's true so people want to blame
the universe for all kinds of stuff
that's happening a lot no it's just you
you just you
hi and you're crazy blame it on your ass
and and and Shakespeare in Julius Caesar
right The Fault dear Brutus lies not in
the stars but in ourselves hey sweet man
just saying that's man Neil deGrasse
Tyson boy I liked hours and we another
one alright well if it's fast okay okay
okay okay I love this cuz I'm I'm always
a fan of this way this is Dan fish or
face book if comets eject their gases
into space do we know of any dried-up
comets the ones that exhausted all of
their gas reserves yes nice question yes
so comets are a mixture of ice and rock
right and the ice when it comes near the
Sun gets heated then it evaporates or
technically speaking it's Sublime's when
you go directly from a solid to a
gaseous state I'm loose in my vocabulary
than I just say it evaporates but
sublimation is the correct chemical term
you've seen sublimation with dry ice yes
ever see dry ice it doesn't melt solid
and then it's not there anymore at all
yes okay so with comets every time it
comes around a Sun it loses some of this
some of its ice okay and eventually you
can have a comet that's just a ball of
debris right moving around the Sun and
it's no longer a comet it's just a ball
of debris and we'll just call it an
asteroid at that point and there are
many asteroids there many asteroids we
think were once comets that are just
dead right now I mean they're living
asteroids with their dead cop like
retired cops that's a better word other
comment 6.1 years that the truth about
Halley's Comet Kalli a 6.1 years it
comes it's time around the Sun varies
depending on what Jupiter does to it
okay be it could be 74 years 77 averages
it averages 70 so do you believe I've
said Mark Twain was born and died in
Halley's Comet
in return we don't have to believe it
it's a fact it's a fact and when things
are facts you don't have to don't have
the relay your human belief system to
accept them you said Jupiter remember
the Jupiter effect remember that
that's the deal that's another segment
the man is on fire he's lit up he wants
more Startalk return more cosmic queries
this is school star talk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson I
serve as the director of the Hayden
Planetarium in New York City yeah means
I have the keys to the sky I want to go
go all right you come on let's go now
run free you got a comedy special and
start on on Showtime yes what's it
called what's it called regular black oh
oh here we go
I do why I call it regular black cause
when growing up in Chicago
Oh my American friends they heard my
parents talking okay and ain't my hair's
a thick access and they look Nigerian
accent yeah and then we were like yo man
were you where your parents were I said
oh I'm Nigerian they're like oh we
thought you like regular black regular
back you know like we from Mississippi
Kentucky we thought you regular no but
what you should have said was I am
African American oh oh that would a bit
oh that would it please back they were
total that would have told that just
nothing they could say that's where that
title comes from so we got um time
special regular bond it's going on now
I'll watch it tonight I'm gonna find a
tool I'll go find it I watched all your
stuff except I didn't have to pay to see
my stuff
no I didn't know you'll have to pay for
Showtime Showtime no I got you spell on
Showtime I gotta go play you get your
package pirated offer free man oh man
I'll call them up and say I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson give me the universe will
come down on
oh that's a good threat
it's all about - here - all the forces
of the universe will come down we're
getting free you would go in and get if
you just want to get some M&Ms like yo
you need to give me these M&Ms for free
the universe will come down on this
whole little bodega you know a lot of
those guys are religious take you had to
do an accent that raises if it's true
it's not racism if it's said by a
comedian yeah so cosmic queries got
cosmic phenomenon alright what do you
have to go the controversies of naming
celestial bodies mm-hmm what's the
controversy what's the what's the
concert it's Rick Roberts asking no
there's no controversy or no concert yes
next question I'm will tell you ready
okay so planets are named for Roman gods
okay okay asteroids were formally named
also for Roman gods when people thought
they were planets okay
then after the first few dozen asteroids
were discovered in the asteroid belt
they said these aren't plans these are
something else we need another word for
them and even though on the sky they
kind of look like a star cuz they're
little and you can't see like a surface
on the causer so there's so little
there's like a point of light so they're
kind of star alike but they're not stars
the asteroid star like you come on this
why we do the world would hemorrhoid be
that's they're out near Uranus lines
near Uranus Neil deGrasse is quick baby
bees attacked attack Ian he's attacking
command it was perfect just trying to I
know my um ROI that's ass like near your
anus booty joke
let justifies the booty Joe science in
their vocabulary
okay now we're okay
so asteroid so then when too many of
those got discovered then we just gave
up and they're named after any person
place or thing okay so there's a there's
a Oh
initially they would name that to
feminized things and objects so there's
an asteroid Mozart Mozart eeeh Mozart
eeeh yeah that's to feminize it because
the asteroids were only named after
feminine the original asteroids are
named after feminine gods why can't roam
and gods okay so now then they just gave
up because there's too many asteroids so
because there's hundreds of thousands of
asteroid and so so I even haven't
there's an asteroid named after me it's
called Tyson no yeah uh my time I says
they're after me so why would it be
enough for Mike Tyson I mean Ann thyroid
oh you're saying there's an asteroid
named Tyson and I'm claiming it's named
after me wondering if his name after
Tyson chicken's so I so so that's those
are asteroids named after person places
things and pets okay there's even one
named after Santa all right so so
asteroids have the most diversity in
what they have been named because
there's so many of there's so many of
them thank you just run out of all the
gods who ever was all right so moons of
planets like Jupiter any moon of any
planet yeah it's named after the Greek
gods that played a role in the life of
the Greek counterpart to the Roman God
after whom the planet is named okay so
Jupiter has one of its moons Ganymede
Ganymede was the man's servant of Zeus
okay
Zeus is the counterpart to Jupiter but
so these two nomenclatures are homage to
the Roman and Greek traditions that have
influenced Western science what about
the growth of Western science I was a
character in in Jupiter's law I remember
all
we're all they were but they're there
look I'm up there there okay
that's right now no this will do more to
this answer than I think either you knew
right yeah okay so now okay so you got
that so it turns out Herschel
William Herschel okay was the first
person to discover a planet the first
part of the planet beyond Saturn for
most of human civilization there was
only Mercury Venus Earth Mars Jupiter
Saturn six planets in fact most of the
time they're only five because we didn't
know earth was one of them ah it was
just Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter and
Saturn okay okay it's murky Venus Mars
Jupiter five plus the Sun and the moon
were counted as planets planets from the
Greek meaning wanderer
which means you move if you wait long
enough against the background stars and
there were seven Wanderers that were
known to the ancients and this is where
we get the names for the seven days of
the week so what days named after the
Sun Sunday after the moon Monday Monday
and in our culture it's a mixture of
Roman and Norse mythology's but each of
those gods corresponds with the
controlling God over those seven
entities okay so then Copernicus comes
around discovers that we're one of these
planets because we go around the Sun
like everybody else and we're not in the
center with everything going around us
so that complicated things just so you
know all right
the coolest name though Nikolas come
Nikolas customers
that's Titus not Galileo Galilei Galileo
Galilei looks lazy that looks lazy okay
you could call the same thing a Pernik
is Nicholas no Copernicus yeah there's a
rhyme waiting to have no wrappers wrap
everything surrounds me baby kurta kiss
baby what's up cap okay keep working on
that and come back all here will hear
without I could Kepler Kepler's tight
Johannes Kepler that's he's badass he
was the first person ever write down an
equation that described physical reality
Wow he wrote that Kepler's laws of
planetary motion that was in early 1600s
so we've only had mathematics describing
the universe
for 400 years okay and he basically
bursted that so getting back to the
names so because because Herschel was
the first to discover a planet no one
had a tradition of naming planets yet
because they hadn't been discovered yet
everyone knew these things in the sky so
there was no tradition yet right so he
just named it after his principal
Thunder which was King George so for
many decades the enumeration of the
planets of the solar system was Mercury
Venus Earth Mars Jupiter Saturn and
George and George yes planet George oh
so now that's kind of that's so me
that's so gangster name its George I
gave you the money
don't try it I want to be a planet this
didn't last internationally it didn't
last but they had to like be nice to the
Brits because they discovered it all
right so as a know my eyes as it
recompense the moons of Uranus rather
than is what this is the only exception
hmm rather than being named for Greek
characters in the life of the Greek
counterpart to the Roman god afternoon
the planet is named Uranus's moons are
named after fictional characters in
Shakespearean literature oh okay so
that's all Maj - there might be one I
don't know just like 60 hello I'll go
check on that we've got Miranda puck
Oberon their lot from a Midsummer's
Night Dream that's okay okay that's
there okay and lastly stars are no
longer really named anymore most of the
stars that have names have Arabic names
although the Arabic tradition is also
preserved in in the modern reckoning of
the names of things after soon while we
just number them in a catalogue okay
comets are named after their discoverers
or people after whom the discoverer
wants to name them but they're named
after people exclusively okay all you
know I know only a headsman Hallie yeah
how is Tony he didn't Haley's or
Halley's
it is Halliday is Haley Haley is Bill
Haley in the comments that that messed
with the proper pronunciation of Edmund
Haley for decades we got go lightning
round three minutes left okay lightning
round
do it okay what do you okay this is bilk
Floyd Facebook what do you think of the
theory that dark matter can be explained
by primordial black hole no because we
could like black holes ordinary matter
and we have accounted for all the
ordinary matter in the unit basically
okay go and Rue de Seine go Facebook do
big bangs only happen in the absence of
everything or can big bangs take place
anywhere and at any time space is
timeless a lifetime for us is a
nanosecond for space so one day could
the universe change yet again could it
evolve for lack of a better word there's
no reason to think to prevent us from
thinking that you've had Cosmo Genesis
even within the space-time that we
occupy so there's talk that our our
universe can have pockets that are
themselves expanding that are separate
from other pockets that are expanding
that are themselves Big Bang universes
Wow
so there's no reason to think there was
only one Big Bang okay and this is the
seeds of the multiverse actually next
describe Oh Jen Bailey Facebook describe
string theory and five sentences five
sentences okay so the frontier of
Einstein's general theory of relativity
and the frontier of quantum physics meet
in the singularities of black holes and
in the origin of the universe itself at
that singularity there must have been a
shotgun marriage between the two where
the physics of the large meets the
physics of the small and in that shotgun
marriage which is currently a
theoretical mystery to us
that is the playground of string
theorists next okay okay these questions
are too long this is PD
Jake regal okay here's a shorty how does
life come from non-life oh sorry we have
no idea that is a biological frontier
how do you go from in or get from
organic molecules to self-replicating
life that is a fascinating frontier and
biology and we look forward to the
solution that in the coming years next
okay here is Rafael Alves
he's from Rio de Janeiro Brazil how is
it possible that the further we look
into the observable universe we see the
cosmic microwave radiation the oldest
light in the universe assuming that it
comes from matter beyond our observable
universe doesn't it mean that the
universe expanded faster than the speed
of light after the Big Bang if the
universe is roughly thirteen point 75
billion years old how could the oldest
photons have traveled around 45 to 47
billion light years towards Earth
how come our thirteen point 75 billion
year old universe is 93 billion light
years across how is it impossible
because the universe can the fabric of
the universe can expand faster than
light there is no law of physics
preventing that the speed of light limit
is anything traveling within the space
that is itself expanding that cannot
travel faster than light the fabric of
the universe itself can travel without a
problem and in yes the early universe
did expand faster than the speed of
light itself there's not a country
whoa you're Murdoch is there any way to
tell how large the universe is as more
light reaches artoo over time we see
more but if the universe was finite
could this stop happening and if so what
would that look like I love that
question you know why because I think
about it all the time oh yes because
there's an expanding horizon it's a time
horizon and in a billion years we will
see a billion light years more of this
universe because that's an extra billion
years that that part of the universe had
to reach us okay okay so now because in
other words if we're only 14 bill at
13.8 billion years old where's the light
from something that's 14 billion from 15
billion years away from us it hasn't had
time to reach us yet
wait a billion years men that comes in
you see that part of the universe now
watch what happens
if in 16 if in 16 billion years age
nothing starts coming to us that would
mean the horizon has washed over the
last bit of matter in the universe and
there'll be no more cosmology left to be
revealed because and that would be then
the literal edge of all the matter in
the universe is done well has not
happened yet which is why there is still
something called cosmology where we can
look far out and see the birth of the
universe itself Oh Godfrey thanks for
thank you for all this is a huge brain
hurts yeah you no longer a cosmic
queries virgin well I'm not welcome to
the Clyde just got banged Big Bang
Godfrey you're on Showtime I'm gonna
find you after I pay my bill for soup no
oh so this has been star talk and I've
been your personal astrophysicist Neil
deGrasse Tyson and has over
[Applause]
[Music]